welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast I'm Gus Docker on this episode I
talk with Ander Sandberg who's a
researcher at the future of humanity
Institute at Oxford University
we talk about anders's upcoming book
Grand Futures which is a synthesis of
many different Sciences physics biology
economics as well as philosophy
it's an investigation into what Humanity
could achieve within the bounds of the
laws of nature and it's really exciting
here is Ander Sandberg
Anders welcome to the podcast
thank you for having me here
are you have been working on a book
called Grand futures for a number of
years now and you sent me a draft of it
it's 1400 PDF Pages wonderful filled
with equations so much depth there
though by perhaps a bit prerogatively my
first question is does it make sense
today to write huge long books or is
that a is that an outdated form of of
research
I think there is a lot of value in doing
that at least for me I'm learning so
much by trying to do this so trying to
frame what I'm doing is
that I want to make a map of what we
know about very long-term future how
good it could be how far we can go in
different directions and a lot of that
is reviewing existing existing material
that scattered across a lot of different
disciplines and putting it together but
as I do that I'm noticing annoying holes
problems discrepancies and I'm trying to
fix it and that is of course research on
its own so indeed some of the the
chapters have become papers on their own
there is one chapter about the longevity
of civilizations but also as a spin-off
became the material for a chapter in a
book on societal collapse I have a
discussion about how long we can make
the biosphere survival but they ended up
in an environmental ethics Journal
but deep down you might wonder couldn't
this be done by an AI program why do we
need a human doing it so my answer is of
course it's good for me I like doing it
it organizes stuff but it's also that
right now we still haven't gotten that
effective way of reviewing a literature
especially since you actually need to
somewhat understand what's going on in
order to see what makes sense because
talking about the future also has this
fundamental problem that there are very
few facts right now out in the world
that tell you whether you're speaking
truly about the future or not which
means that it's hard to test and indeed
there is a lot of blabber sometimes it's
fiction sometimes it's just reactions
onto the future trying to figure out
what you can rigorously say about the
future is a really interesting research
project
but in the end of course I'm not really
expecting a lot of people to want to
read that enormously victim I'm going to
write to a popular version without the
equations but then I can point back to
the big pile of papers if somebody says
Anders you can't possibly move a Galaxy
using aluminum foil then I can bang him
on the head with my big book and say
read chapter 26 it has worked examples
so you you have the the background book
with all of the equations somewhere you
will publish it somewhere or at least I
think you should
but oh yeah it's my top priority uh
because I also want to be able to start
on other books but they're building on
top of it
um I think it's quite important to put
things together as a academic I'm
constantly writing research papers but a
good research paper is about one topic
and usually it has to be a very narrow
topic to get through the review process
in any academic journal and certainly I
can write a lot of papers and then pile
them up next to each other and say see
this points make a beautiful line but
it's sometimes better to actually just
write the book explaining what that line
is what the the things are and then
sometimes it turns out that some parts
of that book might be turned into papers
on their own
do you think there are there's
interesting we could call it hidden
knowledge in between disciplines so when
you combine physics with philosophy or
economics with Biology do we discover
new things
I certainly think we discover new things
culturally because what is well known in
one discipline might be not known at all
in another one for example there is a
set of theorems about
reliability of circuits that are kind of
in the second or third textbook in the
reliability Theory textbook for
electrical engineers
these ones are also applicable for the
reliability of complex logical arguments
in philosophy but of course very few
philosophers have done electrical
engineering so they don't even know that
there have experience but you can apply
to look at the shape of logical
arguments you get some sense of its
reliability
and sometimes of course you have
information about one thing that exists
in one field that is unknown in another
field or methodologies computer
simulation is a very useful methodology
for certain problems but it's mostly
known of course in the exact Sciences
where you can formulate it as math it's
very rarely used in philosophy but
sometimes agent-based simulations are a
perfect way of demonstrating The Logical
consequences of various assumptions you
make explicit assumptions you program
them in and you see what happens
so I do think the interdisciplinary work
it contains a lot of hidden information
mostly because so much information Falls
between the cracks in different
disciplines
one of the biggest issues is that
Engineers know a lot of things about how
to build things how to move things
around practically in the workshop that
is not covered in any of the academic
texts there's a lot of practical
knowledge that is quite important
whether something is easy or hard to do
is quite often hard to discover for me
as an outsider I'm peeking into a
discipline where I actually need to talk
to the people inside to see what
actually works the funny thing is of
course
uh this also means that I'm getting a
tremendous degree of imposter syndrome
I'm writing this extremely
interdisciplinary book trespassing on a
hundred different disciplines the good
news is that being aware of my imposter
syndrome means that I'm now running
around trying to fact check with a
hundred different disciplines hearing
what they say and hopefully also get in
the comments on other parts of the book
rather than just the sub topics that I
might be starting out a question about
I imagine it's rather difficult today to
get an overview of all of science as as
I see this book uh attempting to do I I
mean if you were Aristotle 2 500 years
ago maybe you could know everything that
we knew scientifically but today it
seems almost impossible what if what if
you learned about how much knowledge is
out there from from writing this book
uh so I learned a lot of that it's very
hard to even find what is known in a
discipline because of course it's very
rare that you get a nice list of here
are the main facts that we actually know
even the standard textbook will bring up
a few things usually get the slightly
philosophical introduction that nobody
reads in the textbook and then the first
few chapters outline in the structure
and if you look at the table of contents
we you will typically get an idea about
what the main topics are
but that's of course not all there is to
know about it in mathematics for example
there are thousands and thousands of
theorems that are very important and
many of them have their own names but
you don't know how to find there is no
Google for mathematics that's one of the
uses of AI that I'm really looking
forward to so I can finally ask is there
a theorem that is applicable to this
particular case
now the thing to do is of course to
learn a bit about the shape of fields
different fields are very different
methods and different ways of even
putting their information into place
astronomers are living in a world these
days of databases being very good at
managing databases seems to be an almost
as essential as knowing how to handle a
complex instrument indeed most
astronomers these days are rarely
sitting behind the telescope they're
hunting in a big online databases for
complex statistical patterns and they're
generally much better programmers than I
ever imagined them to be as I got a lot
of very useful tips on Python
Programming at an astronomy conference
this week now the interesting part is of
course those links and those knowledges
between disciplines and the shapes of
disciplines what they know about what we
do and also what we don't do is very
valuable knowledge when you try to
navigate between sometimes it's very
valuable to know what the Border work is
uh What uh words and terms to not use to
have them take you seriously because
they have decided that we need to have a
very firm border against that other so
the science field that is not us
sometimes you want to know that they are
using this method and they don't
recognize that that applies outside
their own discipline
um similarly knowing uh where we're
overconfident is also valuable we saw
that for example in the debate about the
gain of function research in virology so
very some people interested in doing
experiments that generate aphrogenic
organisms but could have Pandemic
potential in order to understand the
better and avoid future pandemics it's
very noticeable that people in other
adjoining disciplines working on other
viruses typically say oh that is very
scary and very bad they understand the
field well enough but they also don't
have the same investment as the people
inside
and I think that knowledge about the
shape is useful so getting back to the
point about trying to cover all of
Science in a book it's not just the
facts of science or even the big
theories of science you want to know you
really want to understand roughly where
the different groupings are what the
disciplines or what their shapes are and
who's talking to whom and who's not
talking to whom and sometimes you find
people who don't even know where ought
to be talking to each other and if you
create even a slender link between them
you've done something very useful
I also see you as trying to understand
what we can do with the science so one
methodology you use is this exploratory
engineering maybe you could explain what
that methodology is about
so in normal engineering you create a
design to achieve some end in the world
to make a card to make a computer to
make a light bulb and uh when you try to
make it possible to implement in reality
ideally as cheaply as possible now there
are many questions about future
technologies that we can fantasize about
we can think maybe we could do this or
that but that is not very rigorous but
you can use the rigorous methods of
engineering to actually make blueprints
for things that don't exist yet and
maybe will never be built but we could
say if we do it rigorously enough but if
we ever built a turbine of this size it
would actually have these properties how
do we know that well we know very much
about classical mechanics we know about
what works engineering wise we know
scaling laws like if I double the size
of this thing it's going to have twice
the same area it's going to have eight
times eight times as much mass and so on
you can apply this to make very reliable
predictions about things that you
haven't built and then you can say
things like in this case it would have a
form following performance
characteristics which is very powerful
for thinking about what you could do
with future Technologies now the
interesting part here is that you can
use this to study the limits of
technology and it's of course very hard
to make a really detailed design so you
can sometimes use a stupid design but
nobody in the right mind would build
um but it's easy to start it's a bit
like in normal engineering where you
don't really know how the safe something
is so you add a safety factor of free
you ignore a lot of the fine details
about how vibrations and shear and the
erosion might affect the thing because
you just made it three times bigger than
what you are fairly confident it's safe
so you make something that is a
theoretical but also likely to work in
reality you can do the same thing with
exploratory engineering now the classic
example of this um is actually from the
British interplanetary Society so in
1939 they made the paper uh where they
analyzed how to build a rocket to send a
man to the moon and bring him safely
back again
1939 it was based on solid rocket fuel
and it had a lot of assumptions which
today we would love might let but it was
a solid engineering design then they had
to stop producing the journal because of
the second world war they were kind of
busy with other things but in the next
issue of the award there was an update
on this report using liquid rocket fuels
because they have seen the V2 rockets
falling in London and now we knew more
about their performance characteristic
and could make a better Design This was
decades before bipolar program and it
was most a demonstration that yes
philosophysics allow us to construct the
system like this they didn't have any
funding and they could probably not even
imagine that the Mayo government would
give funding to such a crazy project but
you can still work out the details later
on we saw another most beautiful piece
so that was the work of Eric Drexler in
outlining nanotechnology basically
demonstrating and using rigorous
chemistry and physics but if you could
build this nanotechnological machines
they would have the following fantastic
performance characteristics you would
get turbines moving at very high
velocity you could perform chemical
Transformations that are very effective
computers that are very very fast Etc
now he didn't prove that you could even
find a pathway from where we currently
or to that wonderful world he has showed
that that wonderful world can exist and
then it's up to us to actually find a
good development path which has turned
out to be slightly trickier than
envisioned in the 1990s
but still I think it's a solid form of
exploratory engineering so this is how I
can be fairly confident but I could move
a Galaxy using aluminum foil I can
basically outline the way of nudging
stars in the tractors by putting
reflectors of Starlight and demonstrate
that these nudges are enough to make
stars change velocity and direction on a
large scale show that this is enough to
rearrange a Galaxy on another time scale
and that would allow me to deduce it as
a kind of crazy rocket to actually give
it a certain velocity I'm not proposing
that this is a good way of moving
galaxies I imagine that you know of some
tens of millions of years when somebody
actually seriously wants to do it they
have invented much better methods but
this shows that the laws of physics as
we understand them today and very very
solid things that we actually know
exists like light pressure do allow us
to perform actions like this
you're exploring what Humanity could
achieve if we so to speak completed
physics or if we reached a technological
maturity as you as you call it in the
book somewhere
um do you think do you think we'll do
you think we will ever reach
technological maturity how fast do you
think we'll reach a technological
maturity
I I think we can be certain we can do
wondrous things even without being uh
that's a technological maturity after
all we're doing some pretty impressive
things already uh if you're not
impressed by a current technology just
ask one of our Stone Age ancestors and
they would be very impressed uh by many
other things we have
but technological maturity it's even
hard to Define what that means does that
mean that you cannot invent anything
more well you can always try to add an
extra fin or really repaint it to your
spaceship there is an infinite amount of
technology that you could make but most
of them don't matter the set of technos
that really matter might be a relatively
small and finite and then it might be
that we're in a kind of rear in the
painting and real you know designing
them a little bit
but technological maturity also might
mean that if you have a need that you
need to fulfill you can start doing that
if there is a machine or a way of
solving that need you will have a way of
getting there and you can do it fairly
fast with small the small resources not
like you the civilization need to drop
over what it's doing and spend a lot of
time inventing things but rather yeah
it's an everyday problem we can just put
our engineer on building it if we then
need it
this depends very much on whether the
space or possible Technologies is
impossible to search through and I have
friends and they're thinking either an
option is possible I have some friends
thinking that nope we are going to reach
technological maturity eventually we're
going to know enough of physics that we
can just build whatever it's needed and
I have other friends say no real
technology is combinatoric we put
transistors together into circuits
circuits together into computers
computers together into internet or
robots or cars we actually
add new modules and every new device we
make increase them when the amount of
ways we can put things together I can
put that microchip into weather station
and now I have a very different kind of
design automated weather stations okay
they are now another object I can add to
some project so that means that you get
a combinatorial explosion
the first group of friends immediately
say yeah but the number of truly
primitive tools
um the Primitive machines are rather
small there was the famous kind of seven
uh basic things like the veg the drill
the wheel and we have added things we
have electric motor we have a PSO
Electric elements and so on they have
loudspeakers we have the LEDs so we have
added a few of these basic menu elements
but they're much smaller than the total
set of the technological artifacts we
have the interesting thing here is of
course that combinatorial explosion is
not necessarily a problem because you
can just do design so an engineer might
decide I'm going to need to make a sound
from my machine so they are just going
to get a catalog apart and look through
various forms of loudspeakers and
vibrators and other tools
they know that they need a module that
does a sort of thing and they know what
section in that big catalog to look at
so in many ways we have ways of
searching for this Infinite Space of
Technologies very efficiently uh if you
set up a project something like the
Apollo project to build let's say on the
moon base again we're not searching
randomly here we are going to have the
tools and ways of getting a life support
system done by the life support
engineers and the solar panels are going
to be handled by the solar panel people
so that modularity means that we can
rather effectively construct new
technologies we also of course also
getting interesting new tools AI for
example is allowing us to do
optimization of various forms very
topological optimization methods that
means that you can construct certain
optimal structures and minimizing
material use so giving them other
properties that are very organic looking
very weird and can only be 3D printed
but that's easy once you have the right
computers and 3D printers
so this back and forth about where the
limits of Technology go I think it's
going to be very hard to resolve I don't
really know where I am up in this
conversation I generally think that
we're probably going to occasionally
find these surprise technologies that
are very different from everything else
but most of the technology we do is the
easy technology because it's modular we
developed a toolkit for doing it you can
order it over the Internet or in a
catalog and actually inventing an
entirely new kind of technology is going
to be relatively rare and as we learn
more I think we are going to end up
finding that to be a rarer and rarer
after a few billion years I would guess
that the rate of totally new
technologies is going to be much smaller
we're not going to discover that many of
it on the other hand for any particular
use you just describe what you want to
your AR program a 3D printer or Mata
compiler and then makes a structure that
solves that problem
how much of Technology do you think
we've already invented so just bear with
me here because it might not make sense
to ask this question but just imagine a
line going starting in in 200 000 years
ago with uh with fire and and stone
tools and so on and ending in
absolutely Advanced uh technology in
fact perfectly advanced technology so at
the limits of this it's where on that
line do you think humanity is now
so I think that on a linear scale we
would probably be very close to the
beginning I think we're very very
primitive however suppose we use a
logarithmic scale instead so every unit
distance was kind of 10 times as much
more technology as before then I
wouldn't be too surprised to to find
that we would be roughly in the middle
culturally this is of course a bit of
just saying it's most likely that you're
in the middle of a line than at the end
but I do think that we have found many
of the fundamental ways of interaction
with with the world indeed when you look
at the signs for nanotechnology in the
drexless Nano systems you find that it's
actually a lot of very recognizable
things like wheels and the the valves
culturally it's because we know how
wheels and valves work so we can
actually make use of that to analyze
even the molecular machine quite
carefully and maybe the actual Nano
mechanisms are going to look utterly
different but when you start looking at
the molecular mechanism inside a cell
you realize that many of them are weird
because we're made out of proteins that
were evolved rather than designed by an
somebody who has a limited bandwidth for
design
but you still recognize a lot of his
motifs
so I think we have found actually quite
a lot of the fundamental fundamental
motifs on how to manipulate the world
there's probably quite a lot of them
remaining I think we're going to find
many more
and then of course just because you're
halfway through this list of motifs
doesn't mean that the consequences of
Technology don't get much weirder
consider for example the transistor the
transistor is a simple thing yet when
you start Mass manufacturing it so it
becomes cheap and small it changes
everything partially because you can
transistorize a lot of electronics so
there are a lot of very disparate
designs become possible to do with just
with transistors and you can computerize
your systems and suddenly a lot of
control is your software and an entire
universe of possible programs can be
used to run whatever the device is and
that software world has turned out to be
much faster than we imagined when people
started out in the 1930s and 40s with
the computer science so while Alan
Turing was a Visionary and understood
that there is an infinite number of
computer programs and also that the
problems that they're not infinite
enough to solve there are many
uncomputable numbers I think he was
still envisioning things very much like
mathematical calculations and finite
State automata moving around
gradually over the decades the
understanding of both the computational
universe was like really like grew so by
the 1970s we had the understanding of
computational complexity we knew that
some algorithms run very fast some are
very slow and there are some problems
that seem to be much harder than others
and we could formalize them we got the
classic fundamental problem is in a very
category P equal to the category MP
which is the big problem in theoretical
computer science and we're still making
progress in discovering non-trivial
things in this domain to this day
that was kind of unexpected this is just
what we got from one device the
transistor it opened up a particular
universe and now of course our
transistors are much fancier than they
used to be but that extra Dimension we
got from computation was a really
powerful addition do you think we are
making differential progress such that
our physics mathematics computer science
perhaps is more advanced than our
biology sociology economics
and I I think it's very much that we're
making differential progress partially
because some domains are much harder to
make progress in physics is potentially
a very clean domain there are general
rules and we can also make very clean
systems that follow these rules and
analyze them and the systems don't
respond back very much well maybe a
little bit on the quantum scale but
generally the systems don't care that
you observe them this is not true for
people people are complicated it's not
just that they are complicated
internally they are also responding to
their own State and responsive state of
others and recognize that we're being
observed and quite often try to game the
system biology is doing somewhat of the
same you both have the effects of
evolution having run ramp out of this
plan for billions of years generating
this tremendous complexity which is just
due to trial and error a lot of that
complexity is very arbitrary you can so
many of the problems in very different
ways but we ended out with frozen
accidents the particular proteins that
are now totally foundational to our
biochemistry and genetics they got set
billions of years ago and now you can't
change them very much they could have
been different but now we are stuck with
that on top of that the platform you
build with other complex systems but a
lot of that is artifacts while very
certainly in a convergent evolution if
you're an organism swimming you see
having a bright belly and the dark back
makes you hard to find for Predators
from above and below so both dolphins
and Penguins do the same thing as well
as various fishes and probably dinosaurs
too but many other things are totally
arbitrary and we end up randomly
searching with voice space which is so
vast that Evolution haven't got the time
to search all of it getting back to that
earlier discussion about search improved
space of possible Technologies we have
some ideas about how to search
effectively better evolution is myopic
and just does nearby stuff now of course
if human biotechnologists come in the
ways things can evolve using
technological Evolution becomes as
arbitrarily tricky as taking the
technology is evolving
so when it comes to our understanding
and the making progress I think some
fields are just much easier to deal with
partially it has to do with
predictability partial it might have to
do with resources we have graphic
sometimes you have a no way of affecting
them like in astronomy but you have the
advantage of living in a transparent
universe so there is light coming in
from all directions where you can see
what happened in the far past and now of
course more recently we can actually
start selling robot out there to poke at
some nearby things
so that kind of window of opportunity
exists in some disciplines but not in
others so the problem here is we might
end up having a grand unified theory of
physics but we're still not going to be
able to say everything about biology
simply because there's a lot of random
stuff that could have happened
differently there might be windows
inside complex Fields Evolution allows
us to understand roughly what's
happening in a lot of biology but quite
often you get weird complications
similarly supply and demand makes a lot
of Economics make sense it's a very
simple and very robust rule except that
there are some cases were very
interesting exceptions and you can't use
just supply and demand to figure out
what to do with your monetary policy
probably I'm lousy at economics I find
it way harder than Quantum field Theory
in the book you you often resort to
physics and computer science chemistry
and anything where we have precisely
defined equations
um and I I I think that's that's useful
because what you're trying to do is
delineate the limits of what we could do
um and so we we should we should talk
about what your conclusions are
about this question of how big the
future could be how Grand could the
future be there are various different
um scales to measure how the big how big
the future could be or their various
aspects of the future to be interested
in
um I had a list here for example uh how
materially wealthy could Humanity become
yeah and just getting back to your intro
here it's worth noting that this
physical boundaries they are simple to
analyze we can do a lot of stuff inside
that but that's going to be culturally
determined and I can't predict culture
nobody can because well it's full of
people inventing reasons to do things
especially and many of these reasons are
nobody has done this or nobody has
predicted this I've got to show off my
Free Will by doing something totally
different
so looking at boundary conditions from
physics is useful but that's not going
to tell us of course that we're going to
be moving up to them but when we think
about material wealth the basic issues
how much stuff can we get and there is
of course an obvious thing about where
the stuff is located in the universe and
how easy it is to move around but from
an everyday perspective how wealthy
would you actually want to be
and I wouldn't be too surprised to find
that a million years from now people are
not owning more matter in the practice
than we are doing it right now because
we don't really care too much about
matter what we want is a delicious meal
what we want is a nice house that looks
really good and our friends like having
a party we want many of these things
that our matter is just one way of
providing you could of course say maybe
you can all move into virtual reality
and get it with a minimum matter but
even if you say well we want to have a
actual real matter buildings
but a lot of those problems are
manufacturing problems the reason it's
expensive to get the house right now is
to a large degree that you need to make
a house and right now you need people to
make it for you you need the architect
to make blueprints you need Builders to
build it you need people to make the
component parts and you need an interior
designer or decorator to put up a lot of
the small data it looks very much like
we can automate most of this that's a
general pattern you see in exploratory
engineering but once we understand how
to do something we can typically
automate that process and then it
becomes orders of magnitude more cheap
or more efficient
uh so making houses by hand is much uh
more expensive than using the
standardized components if you have a 3D
printer for buildings then it becomes
even cheaper of course that 3D printer
might still be expensive but you use it
for a lot to build it so it looks like
in terms of material standards we're
probably going to end up way well feared
but now now there is two interesting
issues here most of that wealth is
probably more in the terms of services
than stuff and second of course what we
care about now is also new dimension
that's sustainability
so our medieval ancestors might have
wanted to have as much gold as possible
and as big and warm houses and as much
food as possible and we would probably
say today yeah gold is not a really
great investment and having a big house
yeah that's kind of nice but it's also
slightly impractical if you're located
in the wrong place and too much food
well have you heard about the Obesity
epidemic actually we change what we care
about we want now we want healthy food
we want ethical food we want food with a
nice story uh going by about that this
is a locally sourced or that this is a
particular old Family Recipe as you get
welfare you switch more and more the
post-material values they seem to be a
generic thing we see in human cultures
but from a practical standpoint I think
we're now going to be using
Manufacturing Systems like
nanotechnology and biotechnology and
Robotics to get both the material wealth
and a lot of service wealth
if we're thinking at the limit of of
material wealth it could it be the case
that we actually become more interested
in matter as time goes on because we are
reaching the physical limits of what can
be done say with a one square kilometer
of of space on Earth uh and so and so
the only way for us to improve expand
whatever it is that we want to do at
that point is to acquire more material
resources for example by space travel
so one scenario might be that the in the
future when the majority of you must
upload themselves and live a wonderful
lives in virtual reality but that still
needs to run on computers somewhere you
need to have your data center that data
center is going to need electricity and
it's going to produce waste Heat
and this kind of interesting note that a
lot of the conversation about material
wealth hinges on can we get cheap energy
and the problem here is if you want
cheap energy well the main source on
Earth for cheaper in the renewable
sustainable energy is sunlight wind is
essentially a derivative of sunlight and
the the much smaller but sunlight only
impinges about the one kilowatt per
square meter at best
so you need a lot of area to do that so
you're saying that we need a lot of area
to produce energy using solar energy but
what what about the Alternatives here
the alternative is to use some form of
nuclear energy which can be much more
intense and I have a lot of other
important advantages so while I'm all in
favor of having a lot of solar nuclear
is very good for at least base load and
in terms of amount of energy you can get
per unit of area it's much more powerful
you need to obviously solve issues about
safety and the non-proliferation of
nuclear weapons but I think those are
doable that I think people have been too
pessimistic of trying to actually
resolve this I think one can do quite
well with nuclear energy not to mention
fusion power if we get that working
but the problem here that is really
serious is waste Heat so imagine this
utopian future we have closed the last
fossil fuel uh the burning systems but
we're using enormous amount of energy
from solar panels and nuclear where does
the waste heat go well it's being
radiated away into space of course and
here's the problem that radiation
happens at the top of atmosphere and we
only have a finite surface area over
there so if we were to increase our
energy usage by about a factor of 100
even if it was perfectly carbon neutral
or carbon negative for all of that I
knew we would still start heating up the
planet simply because the planet has a
finite ability to dissipate energy
indeed this is a fundamental limit even
on how many people you could have on the
planet there had been this ongoing
discussion about what the upper limit of
human population could possibly be and
there is a farm paper from the 1960s
calculating an upper limit to 10 to the
power of 16 people because Beyond that
point the total body heat of these
people is just going to be too much to
radiate away to space
at that point of course Earth is just a
big machine for having people it it's
very dissimilar from what anybody
probably would want to actually have
although that paper also happily pointed
out that you're going to get a million
Einsteins at any point in time not to
mention even more Beetles the offers was
uh clearly not a fan of Beatles music
but
the interesting part here is heat
dissipation is one of those really
fundamental limits that actually affects
quite a lot of the grand systems I'm
talking about
turns out that for computers it's the
same thing if I erase one bit of
information
that information has to go somewhere
otherwise I have a kind of reduced
entropy so the entropy needs to go
somewhere and typically that means it
needs to be dissipated so a really
really powerful Computing Center needs
to radiate away the heat in in some way
and in space of course radiating away
heat is tricky yes the cosmic background
is three degrees Kelvin but uh you'd
still need to use infrared light and
that's very inefficient we are kind of
used to living surrounded by an air that
can convect away and waste it very
cheaply and easily and we never think
about where that waste it eventually
goes at the top of atmosphere but for
very powerful systems you might actually
have to think about this and that goes
also for manufacturing so if you imagine
a method compiler that can just
magically rearrange atoms into whatever
you want sounds like a wonderful thing
until you realize that if I can
rearrange atoms entropy plays a role I
get wasted so if I just completely
rearrange them it actually need runs on
quite a lot of megawatts of power oh
that's going to be hot that's going to
be much worse than the fridge in the
kitchen so actually you want the
transformations to be slower you want
them to not release as much wasted by
being more careful about what molecules
you move around
so Precision is really important the
reason organic life can build so much
stuff without running hot is that it
quite often uses isentropic processes
there is very little real dissipation
going on and this is something that we
obviously might want our own
manufacturing methods to do so they
don't waste too much energy and also
don't produce too much waste product at
the same time we might still want to
speed things up compared to biology
because biology is rather slow if we
have to wait a season for the next crop
of cell phones from the tree they might
be obsolete by that time
how much of the grandness of the future
or potential grandness is dependent on
Humanity leaving Earth or leaving the
solar system and populating space
well that depends a lot on what value
you put on the
spreading but also maybe on Survival so
if we humans live here on Earth with
perfect sustainable uh energy and all of
that the normal lifespan of a species is
about a million of a million years so
you could imagine this kind of humble
Utopia on Nevada City there and then
going extinct after a million years
that's still a lot of future Generations
it kind of vastly more than they
currently have ever lived
but an advanced Society should be able
to handle existential risks indeed so by
even surviving for one million here
means that you actually are pretty
decent at handling uh normal risks at
least the ones you close to yourself but
you would also probably be able to
deflect a bit of asteroids and take
cover when there's a super volcanic
eruption which means that I think it's a
fairly good chance that if we survive
that long we could also survive a mass
extinction level threat that would give
us hundreds of millions of years
probably up to the Natural end of the
biosphere but in about a billion years
the biosphere is going to likely crash
because the increased solar input is
removing carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere and eventually photosynthesis
is not going to work and at that point
the advisor dwindles and also the
thermostat of Earth starts breaking down
and eventually turns into a rather nasty
desert world or a hotels like Venus I
think we can intervene and fix this and
then add millions of years to the
biosphere which I think from even from a
purely egocentric perspective that
doesn't care about humans but only
ecosystem is a good thing to do yet if
we just moved into the solar system and
made self-sufficient space habitats
which I think most people would agree is
technically doable maybe not right now
but if we put our mind to it over the
next few hundred years we could do that
without being too stressed out
if you can mine asteroid material and
turn that into the tools and the the
contents of your biosphere you get
energy from sunlight you can recycle
material well you have enough Surplus
where they could build new habitats and
people can reproduce in them but that
would mean that you must could just
settle the solar system and you could
have a population of trillions of people
that's it not even assuming anything
Grand not like these beautiful pictures
from the 1970s from NASA they're showing
their rotating O'Neal habitat this is
just crappy International Space Station
versions
we can probably aim much higher than
even the grand vicious of the 1970s but
my point here is if you actually can
find this ecological niche taking a
central asteroid material and sunlight
and turn that into an biospheres which I
think very few people think is
physically impossible the biggest
question mark is actually whether humans
can reproduce in space but the one big
question mark we still have then you end
up with a population that can survive
for at least 5 billion years until the
sun turns into a red giant
that's five billion years of a perhaps a
trillion size population that's a lot of
future lives
getting to other Solar Systems is harder
and this is where we get to the question
is that a grand future for Humanity as
we know it because the most obvious way
of getting to another solar system is to
send robotic probes uh and maybe build
things over there using robots and maybe
they can have biological samples and
rare kids with Nanny Bots but no adult
human has ever traveled between the
stores here you just get Humanities
popping up at other settled systems or
as I think is more plausible we
eventually learn how to scan a brain
make a neural network that you can run
on a computer and you have virtual
people going over there and maybe even
turning biologically if they want to
now if you can do this when at least the
Galaxy is available and we should expect
Humanity to survive for a few trillions
of years at the very least because
that's as long as the stores are going
to last
it's a very interesting discussion of
what counts as Humanity I I don't expect
there to be a to be a factual answer
here but it's something that we should
think about morally what what it means
for Humanity to to survive and that is
part of the grandness what is the value
because I can already hear a Critic
saying yeah but having more people for
millions or billions of years who cares
and that's a good point what is so good
about having people around for a long
time indeed we can Envision ways of
surviving much longer beyond the end of
a lifetime of stars after all the energy
sources that could tide us over in the
degenerate era that's much faster far
beyond this what what is the degenerate
area oh error sorry so right now we're
living in this delivers era where there
are stars shining but we're approaching
Peak star in a few tens of billions of
years beyond that the stars are going to
slowly dwindle but red dwarf stars lost
for literally trillions of years
um but in about a hundred trillions of
years we're not going to be a much
Source around yet there is going to be
quite a lot of resources where still
Brown dwarfs that contain a lot of
hydrogen very black holes that you can
dump for example remnants of All Stars
into and extract even more energy than
the store produced during its shining
lifetime so you could definitely imagine
that life and well technological life
could survive in this era and actually
Thrive indeed if you happen to be
uploaded in a computer and care a lot
about saving your energy for computation
the colder it is the easier it is to do
computations without having to dissipate
too much so this might be the time where
all the really big thinking of the
universe actually gets done because it's
too hot right now here in the early
spring
but eventually you run into various
problems some of them I think you can
solve practically like galaxies would
tend to dissolve because of random
interactions between Stars throwing some
stars out of a galaxy and others into
closer and closer to the central black
hole I think that can be handled by a
bit of interstellar traffic control but
somewhere north of 10 to the power of 36
years proton decay is likely to set in
according to most various of physics our
kind of matter is very likely to slowly
disappear and that's probably curtains
for our kind of life
but the real question is of course what
is the value of surviving out until that
curtain time and you could say that well
maybe life's meaning is life itself
Staying Alive is what living beings are
all about we're trying to make sure we
stay alive or our Offspring stay alive
so keeping this unbroken chain uh going
has some special value that is what the
kind of beings we are others with
disagree and say no no I'm totally fine
not having any kids but because I want
to spend my life in contemplation about
higher things or help others and do
other things maybe the unit of selection
is civilizations or chains of
civilizations
or actually doing other things because
maybe some philosophies would say once
you figure out the really important
stuff there's nothing left to do and
then you should just end over there you
have quite a lot of different fears
depending on different fears of value
and philosophy about what we ought to be
doing with the universe but I can at
least give some other boundaries like
okay okay you want to survive to the
generator up here is what you need to
solve the format so you want to do this
big competition well now you need this
many galaxies worth of matter which
means that you need to set off rather
soon because in about 300 billion of
years all the other Galaxy clusters will
have moved away across the cosmological
Horizon so you can't get them if you
wait too long so you need to hurry up a
little bit so we get this interest in
boundaries
but the really interesting thing is
what actually happens is of course
unpredictable but we can start thinking
about the moral Hedges and traits we
want to do there are going to be people
who want humble Futures we just want
sustainability they want to preserve a
natural biosphere and they don't want to
do two weird things they might be the
Amish of the future and ideally just
like the Amish are protected by living
in a decided non-humbled surrounding
Society uh that we might imagine having
a deal but well the post-humans doing
Stellar engineering and weird things
have a deal with the stay at homes to
leave them in peace and quiet and vice
versa and similarly the nerdy and the
superposed humans that want to run a lot
of computation they are just going to be
sleeping up until 100 trillions of years
of time then they take over the universe
but the people who think that's more
interesting to do things in the the
young spring of the universe they are
playing around for the first few hundred
trillions of years
so you can do all sort of interesting
trade-offs and we can start thinking
already now about some of the politics
and how do you make home track that
stick over a long time that would be
useful also of course we're dealing with
our own current governments we want to
figure out ways of making business
contracts and the institutions that last
for a long time so many of these
questions when painted cosmological
sound like their grand science fiction
but I do think many of them are also
very relevant things to solve Here and
Now we can also think about which moral
theories are the most greedy in a sense
where some moral theories will be more
maximalized maximizing than others for
example you might want to have a a
humble Utopia that would be enough on
some immoral theories whereas on other
moral theories you might we might want
to spread into the universe and populate
it with lots of conscious beings
experiencing the heights of of what can
be experienced and so do you think that
perhaps destroys our or hampers our
ability to do these trade-offs if some
moral theories are much more greedy than
others
uh I think it makes the negotiations
more complicated because maximizers uh
will quite often be bad neighbors to the
satisfy those who are satisfied but even
there you can probably find Solutions
because the satisfies might say yeah if
you actually start taking our stuff we
are going to blow it up then you get
nothing
and the maximizers might notice yeah
those satisfices were so annoying
they're actually serious about this okay
in that case it might not be worth
whirling with them I think there are
interesting problems here because
there's some maximizes that can play
along with each other rather well you
could imagine the happiness maximizer
that wants to pave the universe and with
the happiness generating States maybe
they have found some very very Blissful
little mental state of the Mind of a rat
and they would just want to you know
make Dyson Sphere of the Dyson Sphere
full of his States repeating forever
that discovery of a perfect piece of
cheese forever
meanwhile you have a bunch of other
really the knowledge and thought
maximize it you think that's utterly
ridiculous we want to think deep thought
we want to solve the fundamental
problems of philosophy mathematics and
whatever is beyond
and they both want to build bigger
computers so they might now say okay or
we we can't if you can't hack each other
what do you do well you can just agree
to disagree and hope but gradually
convince the other side with good
arguments
because there is an important question
about how much does it cost to have a
conflict and how much does it cost to
negot it but of course the deep thought
maximizes have an interesting problem
they want to have their deep votes
communicated across the society probably
because some of the thoughts might be so
deep and so big that you need a lot of
Minds to do so they need to be coarsely
connected meanwhile the happiness
maximizers are going to say actually the
happiness on one server is totally
independent of the happiness of another
server we are of course very into making
sure there's as many services as
possible but they don't need to be in
contact with each other
at that point the deep thought makes
myself might say yeah so let us take
over the next 20 Mega Power secure of
space we're going to move the Galaxy
cluster together build our the grand
Academy of deep thinking but the rest of
the universe is useless for us because
we can't move those galaxies back into
our Academy servers fast enough the
expansion is always going to win out and
the the in that case why don't you take
them you are not going to get the next
20 Mega parsec but you're also not going
to have a quarrel with us we're going to
defend our service but you get all those
Giga parsecs of Giga parsecs of stars to
turn into those very Blissful uh Rat and
happiness emulating servers that might
be a solution and hidden inside almost
like one of those little imperfections
that make the crystal grow is a little
planet named Earth where it's a lot of
traditional humans having tea and
playing cricket and wondering why the
sky looks so weird
what I hear you doing here is thinking
about how all moral theories apostolate
something that's valuable but whatever
they postulate is valuable it will
depend on the underlying physics and so
therefore we can say something about it
when we're thinking at the limits of
physics so in this sense physics informs
our morality
I think it informs us about our options
and in
what implies can as count famously said
if we find that we cannot do something
then we shouldn't do it either
um so it might be that there are some of
these Grand Futures that because of
unknown physical resource actually we
cannot be implemented in that case we
have a good reason not to pursue them
sometimes you might say yeah we can
satisfice it we can do an approximation
maybe that's the best we can achieve in
this Fallen imperfect world
there are also some issues that happen
that some theories are similar enough
that they might still be competing you
could imagine for example the radical
negative utilitarians that think that
happiness that's nice but pain is bad we
need to really make sure that there is
no pain anywhere and they might be the
really annoying neighbors because they
might say it's actually not a problem
for us but if we get less resources if
we destroy your resources because you
might be generating painful States they
might be very good neighbors to those
happiness maximizes but just run service
full of that Eternal Blissful moment but
they might be super annoying neighbors
to other values so it's not given that
just physics is going to resolve our
moral differences but I think we're
going to find that with some directions
where we can actually make a topology
and figure out where we're likely
conflicts and where where might be good
compromises and the funny part here is
that some of it is set just by the Light
Speed limitation the expansion of the
universe the way information interacts
with entropy this physics actually gives
us some of the marching orders for our
Research into value Theory
I thought I had a very smart objection
to your thinking about Grand Futures at
the limits of physics which is just that
our physics has evolved so much over the
past uh 100 or 200 years so
there must be unknowns that that will
affect what what we will think of as
physics in the future perhaps some of
the fundamentals of physics will change
then it turns out that you have a whole
chapter in your grand Futures book
just dedicated to answering this
question so perhaps we could end by
talking a bit about some of the unknowns
of physics how could things change and
how does this affect our ability to
predict to predict how Grant the future
could be
yeah so so it's pretty obvious that we
have had physical revolutions where we
understood the world in a better way and
many of them have totally upended not
just a little bit of the formats we use
but even the ontology of what's actually
going on when we ended up with
relativity and quantum mechanics our
understanding of what kind of things
actually exist change rather profoundly
yet the clocks over in Switzerland
didn't stop working when Einstein
formulated his equations it just that
now we understand time much better and
we can make somewhat better clocks so on
one level the normal reality we have
must always be compatible with whatever
we find in new physics it just might be
that we realize that actually what
really exists in the universe might be a
handful of things that are actually
Quantum Fields playing out on some kind
of weird space-time manifold there
actually doesn't exist coffee cups and
planets but very excitations and
complicated vermionic matter fits which
is a mind-boggling of the truth but we
still make coffee normally every morning
so the real problem might be that some
important aspects of these theories that
change the direction and turn out to be
wrong in our understanding we have his
term uh The crucial considerations at
the office it's a bit like when you're
out in a forest and navigated by a map
when you realize you've been holding the
map upside down
that piece of information suddenly
changes your strategy completely so it
might be that there's something we find
out about physics that might change
things now it could be that general
relativity is wrong indeed it's not
implausible but maybe the Einstein
equations or the first order terms of
something that is an infinite series of
something but we have a lot of
constraints on that and it's not going
to matter very much at least in the
world of stars and planets and maybe
even normal or smaller but it might
allow us to do very strange things close
to black holes or wormholes or whatever
quantum mechanics is even more
interesting because it seemed to be
fairly rigid you have a few axioms and
if you nudge them even the slightest
things break very badly it's almost a
brittle Theory while you can kind of
change things about around a little bit
in general relativity that is still
allowed Quantum fear is much more rigid
which doesn't mean that it couldn't be
that very very weird things going on in
the way
the to me the most important part is do
we understand the physics of the
information well enough yet and I don't
think we're there yet but it almost
feels like we're approaching some kind
of unification so we have a land hour
principle of linking information Erasure
with thermodynamic dissipation which is
kind of crucial way for me to constrain
what Advanced civilizations can do
because as long as I can reformulate
that as information processing I get a
bound on how much energy they have to
play around it but if that turns out to
be wrong in some sense or that we have a
better way of understanding information
that links with Quantum field theory
that might change things although I bet
that eventually we're going to find more
constraints rather than fewer
constraints
one of the big bounds in my book is
because of the how much you can pack
information together it turns out that
Quantum field Theory hints together with
the theory of black hole entropy that
there is an upper limit on how much
information you can squeeze into a
regional space-time basically in order
to store the information you need that
Quantum field that varies if it varies a
lot you get a lot of energy that then
space time and eventually it turns into
black hole if you try to squeeze up too
much information
these are still somewhat informal ideas
it's not not really truly proven but it
might very well be that we have a
fundamental bound here on how much the
performance you can essentially get out
of anything in the universe as a
computational system
now that is a very important question
mark for me but on the other hand there
are unknown unknowns maybe there are new
kinds of matter maybe new forms of force
fields that probably doesn't matter very
much in everyday life but it could be
just like the semiconductor properties
of silicon are really really modest
things we don't really notice it but
when you around arrange the Silicon
atoms in the right way you get
transistors and computers and the
internet Revolution and suddenly that
there is small property of otherwise
relatively normal element changes
everything and maybe it turns out that
there is a fifth nuclear force and most
of the time it doesn't do anything
interesting but we eventually figure out
a way of tweaking it to do amazing
things this is very hard to predict on
the other hand you can also play around
with things like what about faster than
light travel we can kind of go through
the list of the wish list of Science
Fiction tropes and see what happens if
they're true
and if you get faster light travel
basically you also get time travel
they're equivalent
and this is already a bit Troublesome so
the firmware Paradox where are the
aliens suddenly got much worse because
now you could get visits from Aliens not
just from anywhere in the universe but
from anywhere and of course the normal
time travelers from Humanity's future
and then you realize that actually they
could bring back computational results
you can do computations using time loops
and that turns out to explode the
computational power of computers
enormously indeed classical and quantum
computers become equivalently super mega
powerful and at that point I need to
leave off that discussion of a book by
saying okay if you have Fastenal light
you get these results uh I can't really
imagine much about this weird Universe
we're super intelligences that are way
more Super than I normally would imagine
super intelligence from the end of time
can literally send you an email and
affect your history it's a very weird
universe that's doesn't mean that it's
necessarily impossible but it's so
different from the universe we think of
ourselves living in but we probably
shouldn't be spending too much time
evaluating it at least up until the
first email from before future shows up
fantastic Andrews thank you
thank you
that's it for this episode of the
podcast on the next episode of the
podcast I talk with Anders about the
value of the future from which
perspective should we evaluate the value
of the future and how valuable could the
future be